Our best classical supercomputers are growing more powerful,
and we're becoming better at computation, including simulating systems.
But simulating nature is a very difficult problem in general.
My name is Victoria Lipinska and today we'll explore one of the algorithms
that could make simulating nature possible on a quantum computer.
Let's start with an example and consider caffeine.
It's a simple molecule.
To represent the energy configuration of just one molecule of caffeine,
we'd need approximately ten to the power of 48 bits.
That's ten with 48 zeros
and its about 10% of the number of atoms in the earth.
And it actually gets worse.
If you have 125 orbitals and you want to store all possible
configurations, you need more memory
in your classical computer than there are atoms in the universe.
That's impossible to represent with supercomputers.
There is hope for quantum computers, though,
because they're intrinsically good at simulating nature.
For a caffeine molecule, that would mean representing
the system using 160 qubits.
That sounds much more manageable.
Various quantum algorithms have been proposed that allow
smaller quantum computers to heuristically simulate nature.
Enter: variational quantum eigensolver or VQE.
VQE is an algorithm that runs partly on a quantum
computer and partly on a classical computer.
It allows us to find values that solve a given optimization problem.
VQE is very closely related to other methods involving
variation of parameters like the quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Identifying applications of VQE in your industry or research
is something of an art, but there are loose guidelines.
Generally, VQE is applicable to problems that can be cast
as an optimization problem with continuous variables.
This is the case, for example, in much of quantum chemistry.
Very often, in chemistry, we're interested in the ground state.
The ground state is the state of lowest energy of the system.
In order to find the ground state energy, VQE explores
the energy for different configurations of the system
and looks for the lowest energy configuration.
At a high level, VQE takes in a description of the quantum system
and looks for the lowest energy.
It does this by varying the configuration of the system.
To start, we have to input an appropriate description of the system
that the quantum computer understands and a set of parameters describing it
which will be optimized.
The quantum part of
the algorithm prepares the system in a state
described by a given set of parameters and calculates the energy.
While the classical part is responsible
for optimizing those parameters at each step.
This quantum classical process is repeated
until we reach the lowest energy.
Let's now zoom in on what's going on under the hood.
The energy configuration is typically described in the Hamiltonian
and typically it's a really big matrix.
In algebra, to find the lowest eigenvalue of the matrix
corresponding to the lowest energy of the system,
we would simply do singular value decomposition.
However, the matrices we'll be looking at are exponentially large
and it's an exponentially difficult problem to do this algebraically.
This Hamiltonian has to be represented in the form
that the quantum computer can understand.
So translated from chemistry language to quantum computing language.
No worries on the details though.
Ultimately there is this programable ways to translate the Hamiltonian usually
seen in chemistry into a Hamiltonian understandable for a quantum computer.
We then input this
Hamiltonian together with the circuit, which we call a variational form.
Choosing a variational form is something of an art.
Again,
it represents our best guess on what the quantum state of the system could be.
This variational circuit is parameterized with a set of parameters theta,
and we also input an initial choice of these parameters.
Based on this, the quantum part of VQE:
prepares the reference state, for example, the zero state;
uses a parameterized quantum circuit, the variational form, to prepare a quantum
state for an initial guess of parameters on the quantum computer; and it estimates
the energy corresponding to the state evaluated through the Hamiltonian.
This energy estimate is then fed
into the classical optimizer, which finds a new set of parameters.
The parameters make their way back to the quantum solver again,
and the whole process is repeated.
The quantum computer finds a new energy estimate, the
classical optimizer finds a new set of parameters and so on.
We repeat this process until the solution converges.
That means until the difference in outcomes between steps is small enough
for our needs.
At the end, the algorithm returns that minimized energy.
Okay, this is great.
But you might wonder how do we know that this actually works
and that we won't accidentally find energy lower than what we're looking for?
That's a great question.
It turns out that we can never estimate an energy that's lower.
This is thanks to something that we call a variational principle.
The variational principle states that the greatest lower
bound on the energy of the system is always its
lowest energy corresponding to that ground state.
This means that energy evaluated on any other state of that system
will always be greater than the lowest energy.
Therefore, with VQE we can never obtain something
lower than the ground state energy.
However, we can indeed converge to something
greater than the minimum we're looking for.
This is oftentimes called a metastable solution
and its a challenge that researchers try to solve on a daily basis.
VQE is useful because it uses shallower circuits
compared to other protocols that allow us to estimate ground state energy.
This makes it suitable for near-term quantum hardware.
In this video, we had a glimpse of what VQE can do and how it's built.
But I encourage you to explore Qiskit in this context.
Even though we're still at the beginning of our quantum journey,
you might already find it useful for problems you're trying to solve.
My name is Victoria Lipinska and this was an overview
of the variational quantum eigensolver algorithm.